Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoy the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on guys. This is.
Rob and on today's episode of beyond a mega level,
we are going to discuss what may possibly be the most powerful version of the
Hulk that you've never heard of. This is the blue Hawk.
So this version of the whole first appeared and captain universe,
the incredible Hulk number one written by Jay Faber and drawn by Carlos Magno in
2005. Not only is this his first appearance, but it's also his only appearance.
So this is a very short-lived character,
but one that is nonetheless immensely powerful and come on, it's a blue Hawk,
man. So we have to cover it.
So this issue opens with Bruce banner alone in the wilderness with his foot
caught in a bear trap.
Now the pain he feels triggers his transformation into the whole who rips the
bear trap off and is immediately visited by a floating blue orb pet tells the
whole, it means him no harm that needs the assistance of Bruce banner.
Now the whole initially refuses to allow banner to retake control,
but the orb turned the whole blue and manipulate his emotions to calm him down
and causes him to revert back to banner. And it's here that we learn.
The org is actually the unit power. Now,
if you're not familiar with the unit power,
it is a seemingly limitless source of cosmic power that bonds with those of
noble spirit in times of crisis,
granting them nearly unlimited power and basically transforms them into a cosmic
superhero known as captain universe.
Now the power is bonded with several characters in the Marvel universe,
including Bruce banner,
who recognized the power as it had once bonded with him to split him from the
hole in an attempt to rid himself of what he viewed as a curse.
Obviously it didn't work, but banner is excited to have another try.
Now the unit power informs him that the reason for his visit is different.
This time as the power itself has been compromised and is in a weakened state,
that's where the unit power seeks to bond with the hole and replicate his power
and also wants banners assistance in finding a scientist named Dr. Gilbert
Wiles, Earth's foremost expert on the unit power to try and figure out why it is
weakening.
And so banner is initially hesitant to help because Dr. Wiles is a Manhattan and
he's afraid that if he turns into the Hulk,
he'll be a threat to all the people there.
And we learned the reason that he's in the wilderness is to be far enough away
from civilization, that nobody will get hurt if he transforms.
And so after receiving assurance from the unit power that the whole ego is being
repressed, banner goes to Manhattan and finds Dr.
Weil's now wanting to conceal his true identity.
Banner introduces himself to Dr. Wiles as Bruce Barnes.
Who's looking for information about the unit power shortly thereafter.
They're joined by Dr. David Garrett,
who says he's bankrolling Wiles research in hopes that unlocking the secret of
the unit power will be beneficial for mankind.
Suddenly Gary gets a call from agents from advanced idea mechanics that are on
board.
A submarine that informed here at the unit power is currently inside banner.
Meanwhile, Wiles tells Garrett that he was also once the host of the unit power.
When a plane he was on was hijacked and he was able to use his powers to thwart
the hijackers and safely land the plane. Then as swiftly as it arrived,
the power left him and had been searching for more knowledge of it ever since
now, Garrett then announces that he knows of the unit of how his presence within
banner and fires a beam at ambit drives the unit power from banner Hoke.
Of course then takes over and is immediately attacked by two robots that were
flunking Garrett. Now,
once the AME agents realize who they're dealing with the open up their entire
arsenal to fight the Hawk,
including weapons that had not yet been tested and it's a whole quickly gains
the upper hand,
but as soon overpowered by the robots who hit him with a beam of some energy
that appears to cause him great distress, however, the unit power, reappears,
and merges with the hole again. And once again,
turns him into the blue version of the hole.
Now what the powers of captain universe hope remarks now hope is really the
strongest one.
There is suggesting that his power level far surpasses any power that he's ever
encountered hope easily to feeds the robot that were attacking him and turns
around to see the body of David Garrett with Dr. Weil standing over him,
whole concludes that Wiles has killed Garrett,
which he thinks was the right thing to do, obviously,
but Wiles informs him that it was actually the bonding process, which we,
the unit power and the Hawk that produce a flash of energy that killed Garrett.
And so as the police descend upon the scene, hope, wants to stay in fight.
The banner,
convinces him to leave which results in Wiles being arrested for Garrett's
murder. Now later we see Bruce banner calling Matt Murdock from a payphone,
and that's where the issue ends.
And this would actually go on to be a crossover series where the unit power is
passed from hero to hero. And so in the next issue,
which reveals that Matt has agreed to represent Wiles,
the unit power bonds with Derek. And then of course it goes on from there. Now,
maybe we'll cover this story if it's something that you guys are interested in,
but for now, we'll just focus on the blue hole. As I said earlier,
this is unfortunately all the we get to see of the blue for the unit power
leaves him. And as far as I know, never bothered with him again.
And the really disappointing part of the whole having this power for such a
short period of time as if we don't get to see him use the power to its full
potential, not by a long shot. He just beats up some robots in the lease.
And so it's sort of a dissatisfying conclusion,
but even though we never get to see it fully realized central of the Hawk being
bonded with the unit power is a mince.
And just to get a sense of why through the abilities that the unit power
typically grants its hosts.
So typically anyone who possesses the unit power has their appearance changed to
Donna captain universe uniformed. But this change is not just a static.
It actually grants an extra layer of protection to the user by forming a
protective layer of molecules around them that protects them from radiation,
extreme temperatures or any number of harmful substances while the Hulk does not
Dawn the traditional uniform of Katelyn universe, he does turn blue,
which means that his layer protection is probably present for him as well.
Other hosts of the unit power have also displayed a wide array of powers,
such as flight telepathy and have been able to manipulate energy time and even
matter in reality. And so when we're talking about the unit power,
it can turn anyone at bonds too, into an entity that is well beyond Omega level.
And that's especially true with someone that's already as powerful as the Holt
is granted. The unit power was weakened possess the Hulk,
but I still think that we only saw the smallest fraction of what the hole was
capable of doing with it and shame that we didn't see him keep it longer or go
up against a bigger threat during the short time as the blue Hawk.
But that's about it guys. Like I said, only a brief appearance as a blue hole.
And while we didn't really get to see much adamant,
knowing what we know about both the Hulk and the unit power,
we know he would be capable of some incredibly impressive feats if he needed to.
And we were talking about an incredible hope that would have virtually any
superpower. He needed an energy projection time, travel,
reality war being matter of manipulation on a universal scale,
all kinds of crazy things, right? It really would be a ridiculously Opie Hawk.
And to give a guy's perspective,
this goes way beyond heart of the monster Hawk way AB on that way beyond Herald
of Galactus whole, this, this turns hope and to a cosmic entity.
But with that being said, guys, we're gonna bring this video to an end,
let me know down in the comments section, what video you want me to do next,
right? Because we're kind of running out of characters to do. And honestly,
I kind of liked the idea of mashing up characters that we don't normally get to
see. Right? Like if we had Franklin Richards who got the infinity gauntlet,
or if we had iron man who had the power of the beyond hours,
or like if Wolverine became the specter from DC comics, right.
We've got to learn to think out of the box guys.
We've gotta learn to think out of the box and make up our own stuff. But anyway,
yeah, guys, we're gonna bring this video to an end.
Thank you guys for watching and we'll catch you all later.
Bruce.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].